Keep in mind that for responsive images, like adaptive
layout that we learned about in the last few lessons,
we frequently will want to adapt the size of the
image, the layout size of the image, depending on how
much space we have. Sometimes we do that with
simple scaling, for example, here, on our conference app, we're
currently rescaling the speaker images depending on the layout size.
Sometimes though, we may actually want to switch between subjectively
different images too. For example, you might want to crop your subject
more closely when you don't have as much space to render the image.
Using images differently in terms of
art direction in different scenarios is part
of what makes these responsive images
rather then just scalable pixel ratio images.